breathing's u.s. Airlines I am here to
talk to you today about the
revolutionary a380 superjumbo jet what
now European and Asian airlines are
enjoying our double-decker plane but
you're not you're missing out let's
solve that problem actually its Airbus
that has the problem after 20 years and
making 132 a380s you want to know how
many they've sold to a US airline the
a380 is perfect for the American market
it has two levels it can carry more than
500 passengers at one time it's a cool
airplane but try filling one every day
see Airlines used to be in the business
of market share they would practically
give away a seat if it meant preserving
their numbers but in the last decade
they have pursued the comparatively
novel idea of actually making money
that means stuffing smaller planes to
the gills with high paying passengers
look around the globe airlines like
Singapore and Emirates are flying the
a380 don't you want to compete with them
not really no it's an entirely different
game here over there it's about moving
large numbers of people in and out of
big hubs here in the US we tend to move
smaller groups of people on nonstop
flights in between small and large
cities properly configured why the a380
could hold as many as 800 passengers
consider the savings the efficiency oh
the US airlines hate that idea see they
and their customers prefer flexibility
why only scheduled one flight with 800
people when you could schedule five
flights that carry a hundred and sixty
and with those smaller planes you can
fly them several times a day you want to
know how many times you can fly an a380
about four times a weekend Oh what about
Airport congestion you have a limited
number of landing slots surely you'd
like to get the most out of each one
a380
new air traffic control systems can
safely move more planes in and out of
airports Airport congestion kind of has
a way of solving itself sorry
perhaps you'd be interested in an old
Concorde